une voiture arrivant au col de
l'annuaire banal penserez-vous
[Musique]
mais quand une jeune et jolie personnes
descendent de cette voiture dont nous
avons pu apprécier les performances sur
un circuit particulièrement difficile
que l'on s'aperçoit que l'on peut
allonger les sièges que l'on peut
escamoté une partie du volant tout cela
avouez le vous donne envie
même en cette saison de faire du camping
d'autant plus que vous pourrez dans
cette ariane faire monter les mêmes
éléments de confort que ce que vous avez
sous les yeux
depuis la cuisine modèles jusqu'à l'eau
courante
[Musique]
m
à
en passant bien entendu par la tante au
fait
n'êtes vous pas tenté
[Musique]